[Music]  we are an interactive social media  experience  so we're in our first room the emoji  room and so here you can take cool  pictures create cool content for like  your instagram or your facebook or if  you do tick-tock it's the perfect place  and today anyone can be an influencer so  we want to create a space for people to  be influencers and create their content  you have the lightning you have the tic  tac  music you have the  you have snacks you have all the things  we like we don't you don't have like  90s 90s era or 80s area you have the  2020  era i think that's good  [Music]  i think it's too late to worry i think  that's the way the world is now and i  think in terms of setting a site for  taking wild photos it's kind of good i  mean i think it serves its purpose  [Music]